Speaker 1: Republicans held more hearings
yesterday. These are hearings where Republicans
are determined to show that the FBI has been
weaponized by the left against the right. The
first problem that Republicans had yesterday in
making that case is that they had testimony from
Christopher Wray. Christopher Wray as the director
of the FBI. Christopher Wray is a Republican.
Christopher Wray votes for Republicans. And
Christopher Wray was the selection of Republican
President Donald Trump to lead the FBI. And yet
this did not stop Republicans from making fools
of themselves with all sorts of allegations.
You're defending Hunter Biden, you're covering
for the Bidens. You're targeting Republicans, none
of which are based on any actual evidence. We're
going to look at these clips. And the point
that I really want to hit home here for you
is that this is our money being spent. We talk
about, you know, I pay taxes. I don't like my
money being used for so many weapons. I don't
like my money being used for wars. Fine. I agree.
I also don't like my money used for political
theater that goes nowhere, uncovers nothing.
And it is this sort of thing. Now, our our
friend, Congressman Ted Lieu, a Democrat,
he had a brilliant line of questioning. We're
going to get to the Republican questioning in
a moment, which was which was cuckoo. Ted Lieu
had a brilliant line of questioning here that
speaks for itself. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: Trump adviser Roger Stone
was convicted in a federal court. Correct?
That's my recollection. Trump donor Elliot Brady
was convicted and a federal court, correct.
Also my recollection the attorney general at the
time for those two convictions was Bill Barr.
Which president nominated Bill Barr for attorney
general? President Trump. Trump's former lawyer,
Michael Cohen, was convicted on two separate
occasions and a federal court, correct?
I believe that's correct. The attorney general
at the time for Cohen's second conviction was
Matthew Whitaker, which president appointed
Matthew Whitaker as acting attorney general?
President Trump. Trump's former
campaign chairman, Paul Manafort,
was convicted outside of court, correct?
Yes. Trump's former deputy campaign manager,
Mr. Gates, was convicted in a federal court.
Correct. That's my recollection. His campaign
foreign policy advisor George Papadopoulos,
was convicted and in federal court, correct?
True. Yes. He pled guilty as it attorney out in
the time of those three cases was Jeff Sessions,
which president nominated Jeff Sessions
for attorney general. President Trump,
you were there FBI director for all of those
cases at the time. Which president nominated
you? President Trump. What these facts show is
we don't have a two tiered system of justice.
We have one Department of Justice that goes
after criminals regardless of party ideology.
All of these folks were convicted under
the administrations of three separate
Republican attorneys general. It is not
the fault of the FBI that Donald Trump
surrounded himself with criminals.
Speaker 1: This is, of course,
such an obvious point that I can't believe needs
to be made. But the vast majority of those who
were convicted under this supposedly weaponized
FBI were convicted under the leadership of a
Republican FBI director and Republican attorneys
general. Now, this was like the best moment of
this entire hearing. We then get to some of the
cartoonish moments. Here is Republican Congressman
Chip Roy trying to make the case that the FBI
has behaved in a tyrannical way. And FBI Director
Wray struggling to get a word in edgewise, but
managing to explain why that's not the case.
Speaker 2: Your job is to protect the American
people from a tyrannical FBI storming the home
of an American family. I could not disagree more
with your description of the FBI as tyrannical.
And I don't believe that the tyrannical FBI agents
were a part of storming your father's home or the
gentleman in suburban Philadelphia. Mr. Chairman.
Speaker 1: I wish they would
let witnesses answer questions.
Speaker 2: Time. The gentleman's expired.
Witness may respond, and then we'll move to our
next witness. Respectfully. They did not storm
his house. They came to his door. They knocked on
his door and identified themselves. They asked him
to exit. He did without incident. Or whenever our
agents will not at gunpoint. Whenever our agents
conduct an arrest, their arms, our agents are
armed virtually all the time, as you may remember,
from your own experience as a prosecutor.
Speaker 1: What's so funny about these arguments
that they make? These are the arguments that went
on the left. Concern is expressed generally about,
you know, sometimes when some of these warrants
are served. Do we really need so much firepower?
And Republicans go, absolutely. It's dangerous
out there for members of law enforcement. They
must be armed at all time. This is just the way
it is. Bah bah, ba bah bah. Now all of a sudden,
armed agents, by which we mean like they carry
the handguns as all of these individuals do,
showed up and knocked on the door. Oh, my
goodness. That's oppressive use of force.
It's militarized. Where were you guys? Were for a
decade we've been talking about the militarization
of police forces, for example, pathetic
hypocrites. Then we go to Harriet Hagerman.
She accused Christopher Wray of
discriminating against Republicans,
and he explains, I'm a Republican and
just none of this makes any sense.
Speaker 3: Mr. Wray from the Twitter files
Missouri versus Biden Disclosures, The Durham
Investigation and Report and exposure and Collapse
of the Russia Russian collusion Hoax. The American
people fully understand that there is a two
tiered justice system that has been weaponized to
persecute people based on their political beliefs.
Speaker 1: Of course, most people don't believe
that and there's no evidence of that.
Speaker 3: And that you have personally
been weapon that you have personally worked
to weaponize the FBI against conservatives.
I asked Mr. Durham about this, to which he
answered, I don't think that things can go too
much further with the view that law enforcement,
particularly the FBI or Department of Justice,
runs a two tiered system of justice. The nation
cannot stand under those circumstances. Director
Wray, what are you prepared to do to reform
federal law enforcement in a manner which
earns back the trust of the American people?
Speaker 2: Well, first off, I would disagree
with your characterization of the FBI
and certainly your description of my own
approach. The idea that I'm biased against
conservatives seems somewhat insane to me,
given my own personal background as to how
we are approaching our work of protecting the
American people and upholding the Constitution.
It starts with me having emphasized to all of our
folks over and over and over again in everything
we do that we need to do the right thing in the
right way. And that means following the facts
wherever they lead, no matter who likes it.
Speaker 1: This is your money being wasted. The
money that is being wasted on this hearing could
go to almost anything and it would be a better
investment than this. Then we go to Matt Gaetz,
congressman from Florida. Matt Gaetz tries
to make the case that the FBI is just simply
not trusted right now. And Christopher Wray
says so many people, even from your state,
Congressman Gates, are desperate to work for us.
Speaker 2: People trusted the FBI more when J.
Edgar Hoover was running the place that when
you are. And the reason is because you don't
give straight answers. You give answers that
later a court deems aren't true. And then at
the end of the day, you won't criticize
an obvious shakedown when it's directly
in front of us. And it appears as though you're
whitewashing the conduct of corrupt. Respectfully,
Congressman, in your home state of Florida,
the number of people applying to come work
for us and devote their lives working for us
is over up over 100%. We're deeply troubled.
Speaker 1: And then Gates tries to pin
protecting the Bidens on Christopher Wray,
of which there is, of course, no evidence.
Speaker 2: I will make certain that between the
man sitting next to me and every person he knows
and my ability to forever hold a grudge that
you will regret not following my direction. I am
sitting here waiting for the call with my father.
Sounds like a shakedown, doesn't it, Director?
I'm not going to get into commenting on that.
You you seem deeply curious about it, don't you?
Almost suspiciously. I'm curious. Are you
protecting the Bidens? Absolutely not. The FBI has
no interest in. You won't answer a question about
whether or not that's a shakedown and everybody
knows why you won't answer it, because to to the
millions of people who will see this, they know it
is. And your inability to acknowledge that is
deeply revealing about you. But let's go now.
Speaker 1: The truth is, it would be completely
inappropriate for Christopher Wray in a setting
like this to just weigh in on the meaning of
alleged quotes about India. It's completely
outside of the scope of what the FBI director can
and should be doing. But what we have to remember
is that, to me and to most of you, we see this and
we go, this is nothing. This is like when you pour
water on cotton candy and it just evaporates
into nothing. It's not literal evaporation,
okay? It crumbles into nothing. But the MAGA
people will see the symbol go. Ray is suspicious.
It is suspicious that he won't weigh in on these
things. Just out of the blue that Matt Gaetz
brings up a waste of my taxpayer money. A waste
of your taxpayer money. But to some degree, it is
accomplishing its goal, which is to weaponize
the hearings against federal law enforcement